you've achieved so much uh in in film
and you've written this beautiful Memoir
and you've been an activist and then
sometimes I forget there's this part of
your career that anyone else could hang
their hat on which was the exercise
videos anyone else who had done that
that could have been their whole claim
to fame it was it's such a massive
phenomenon and I think it got so many
people thinking about their health
that's a gift that keeps on giving it is
yeah it wasn't until I wrote my Memoir
and then I did a national book actually
an international book tour but when I
was in this country doing a book tour
you know and when you have a book that
you've written people line up to have
you sign their books and there was
mostly women and they would there'd be
some women that would wait until it was
all done and then they would come to me
and they would say do you remember I
marched with you in 72 in San Diego you
know and then someone else would say
this is often cat balloon yeah capital
is my favorite movie oh my God that
meant so much to me and somebody else
would say your exercise video let me uh
recover from a mastectomy you know you
enabled me to be able to move my my arm
up and and I realized I've connected
with people in this country on so many
different ways yes yes you have it took
me by surprise I hadn't really realized
it you know I think it's lovely that
that if anybody connects with anybody uh
or with fans in one way that's
spectacular but you know you've done
something when someone comes up and says
Jane I have to tell you it could be one
of 175 things that you've done that
meant something to you yeah and it could
be part of your activism it could be as
you said the exercise videos it could be
one of I mean even if okay what's
restricted to film you can't I can't
count the number of films where you've
had a huge impact so that is a
remarkable do you remember Lyndon
larouche Linda larouche was a horrible
man who this was quite a turn by the way
if you're driving right now I hope you
didn't just crash into a tree do you
remember Lyndon larouche no one else
says that but I do yes this will get
back you know he would send people into
gay bars with chains that to beat up
gave people he had people standing at
the airports holding signs you know like
feed Jane funded to the way you know
terrible mean signs and I read an
article this was like 1977 we were in a
recession that he funded all of this
from a business a computer business and
I thought
I was married to the Irishman then Tom
Hayden I said we got to start a business
because we had a Statewide organization
the campaign for economic democracy it
was hard to fund it's a you know huge
State we had offices up and down the
state and so we spent a year thinking
what business
a restaurant neither of us know anything
about food you know or whatever whatever
and then a very smart man
um who started Delancey Street it was a
house place where people could go who
were recovering from addictions and
things like that John Marr and he said
don't ever start a business that you
don't understand well that brought me up
short because the only thing I really
understood was exercise and I had met a
woman named Lenny kazdan who was doing
this workout and we turned it into a
business that funded the organization
it's incredible yeah copied Linda
larouche
now to be fair I've watched Lyndon
larouche's exercise videos and he's
wearing the leg warmers
I gained 200 pounds and an ulcer yeah
it's um
it's funny how you you bring that up
there's I mean even today we live in a
world where there's so much anger and
there's so and there's sensation so many
people that are angry about how someone
else is living their life which I never
understand do you know like if it
doesn't how does that concern you if
someone else is living their life a
certain way why is that well if you're
suffering yeah and you know that you're
suffering because the
in Washington
the neoliberals of the last few
many decades
pay more attention to Wall Street and to
money and to bankers
than they do trying to serve me living
in the midwest in the Rust Belt and so
if you're suffering and you grew up with
your dad belong to a union and his dad
belonged to a union and they could
afford to buy a home and send their kids
to school and now you can't and now you
have to take a job and as a waiter of
course you're going to be angry yeah of
course and that's why these
elected officials have to start paying
attention not just thinking because the
Dow Jones look a certain way that the
people in the midwest are going to be
feeling okay they're not I think one of
the things that that gets to me though
is I think the anger is clearly
legitimate it's when people exploit it
get elected on it and then don't don't
do anything to really address the issue
yeah I don't know who you're thinking of
we won't mention his name is it Lyndon
larouche
you didn't see that coming but yeah it's
uh it's it's fascinating to talk to you
and to see yours fired up and passionate
now
about pretty much everything we've
talked about as you would have been in
1975 and I'm wondering if like
everyone's always trying to figure out
what's the way to age and stay healthy
clearly you are the greatest example of
being able to achieve that and in style
but at the same time I think
you know people wonder what is it what
is it and some people say it's staying
connected and I think also passionate I
mean you're that interested interested
and curious as you get older if you've
stayed interested and curious you
realize that it's all connected there'd
be no climate crisis if there was no
racism
there'd be no climate crisis if there
was no patriarchy it's a mindset that
sees things in a hierarchy you know
white men are here everybody else is
down here plants and other animals are
down here and they see a tree
flooring oh that would make a great
floor you know or a door or you know
everything is to be exploited and
monetized that's led to the climate
crisis since it's all connected and
and so when you know how can you not
stay passionate about trying to do
something about it yeah because we have
so much potential I mean we're so
brilliant as a species my God yeah and
the world is so mysterious and wonderful
and complicated and deserves protecting
we don't even understand the half of it
I did fire drill Fridays this morning
and my guest was a guy named John
hosover who's he's a he's a marine
biologist and he can he he knows how to
Pilot a Submarine underwater he can go
to the depths of the ocean and you know
he's seen things that we don't even know
what they are or what they can do and
and here we are talking about deep sea
mining that would destroy it all I mean
we need humility
and we need to get rid of greed yeah and
we need to understand that the
collective is what's important yeah well
I think humility is with a capital H is
massive it's such an arrogance when
people think well it's 2023 and we know
most of what mankind needs to know and
we don't know anything they're
constantly finding I mean 100 years from
now they will laugh at what we thought
yeah now and if we're even around in a
hundred years I'll be here because of
our ignorance
you'll be here you will be here we'll be
bobbing on the ocean
my little pompadour sticking out of the
water I have pompadours standing up like
a wave